let's bring in military analysts retired
Air Vice Marshal Sean Bell so Sean do we
know why lukashenko has picked this
moment of course so soon after uh
another diplomats meeting between Russia
and China to visit to visit China you
were never quite sure whether it's
lukashenko's beckoning or it suits
China's beckoning to be fair but they're
discuss a range of topics during the
three-day visit
um almost certainly the 12 point plan
that China came up with for the piece
we'll probably discussed as also will be
potential for China to offer a weapon
support but the most likely agenda
behind all of this is that China's
relationship with America has sunk to a
new low after the Spy Scandal around the
uh spy balloons and actually
um the Chinese will almost certainly
judge that by opening conversation with
Russia and Belarus will encourage
America to soften its stance to China to
try and make sure that balance Works in
Belarus though um it's not all going um
lukashenko's way a Russian military
aircraft was at a military base uh in in
Belarus very close to Minsk the A50
Mainstay here it was attacked by
anti-government forces though some drone
attacks two explosion third one that
apparently damaged the front one damage
the middle of this airplane these are
strategic assets that the eyes and the
ears over the battlefield for Russia
they've only got small numbers of them
allegedly about seven they've lost one
more so undoubtedly this will be it will
impact Russians military capability well
let's talk about uh both sides military
capability and give us an update on on
the ground and uh Russian forces
tightening their their grip around
there's a lot of fighting all the well
on the front line up so north of cremina
up here the fighting continues but the
Russians Bible accounts have made some
advances but it's very difficult to
actually get those corroborated but as
you say the main effort around back moot
here the pincer seems to be tightening
Russian forces are moving seem to have
the north of back Moot and a lot of the
South as well at the moment
interestingly the cremuth which is
actually to the west of back moot
there's a road back moot to crimov here
which is a way of providing resupply to
Ukraine that's now coming under the fire
from the Russians so it looks very
likely that it won't be long before
Ukraine will have to make the difficult
decision about whether to stay or go the
other thing that's in the news today is
about Mario poll we haven't talked much
about that since it fell back in May
last year but actually ever since the
21st of February there's been 14
different explosions around Marry You
Paul including attacking some of the
artillery weapon dumps there not quite
sure what's caused them it could be
resistance Fighters it could be special
forces it could be long-range weapons
but undoubtedly all of that even though
it's 80 kilometers away from the front
line seems to be softening up Russian
Logistics potentially ready for some
spring offensive and the other story
that we were we were focused on earlier
is that president zielinski has removed
one of his top military leaders talk us
through the thoughts behind that yeah
Major General Edward muskaviov who's the
Joint Forces Commander been in place
ever since March of last year so he's
done an amazing a job there was no
explanation on why uh president
zielinski got rid of him now it's quite
usual to rotate military commanders
during war the pressure on their
shoulders is immense you often need
fresh ideas fresh impetus for the war
also at times the political military
pressure that causes friction they're
not always going to agree the political
objectives he's trying to achieve and
whether the military price is worth
paying we honest answer we see we don't
know there was only a one-liner
associated with this which is highly
unusual but almost certainly reflects
the very difficult situation that the
Ukrainian military find themselves at
the moment Sean as always thanks so much